[Musica]
benino ma raccontando in modo completo e
maturo mai dovuto tutto li vedi in piedi
anche tu ti devi un po è per te anche
per te abbiamo un po di te anche per
terra e non pochi pensavano jano st
tavano
questi sono i miei amici e ci sono il
cappellaio matto i tuoi amici
sì abbiamo topino gattina è vicino
abbiamo anche le fantino stiamo
festeggiando il compleanno mio
compleanno per caso oggi è il suo
compleanno
no e allora festeggia siamo ha detto
compleanno auguri a chi tocca a te così
qui primario istituto e noi no come no è
assolutamento festeggiare un solo
completato per noi è no guarda veramente
preferisco di no sto bene anzi magari
torno al piano di sopra in camera mia e
mi lascia tranquilli qui a festeggiare
tutto per le componenti offrire un po di
te prima di noi
veramente no nonostate ho bevuto un
patto di android ci siamo noi sono un po
di te ma non c'è niente ma perché ve lo
devo versare
questa è la teiera sempre faccio io non
c'è problema
vediamo un po come questo te
[Musica]
signor cappellaio se c'è qualcosa che
non va in questo tè verde massimi 100 è
un magico l'inter vende a pettino siamo
ben fatto e solo che il colore sembra un
po strano me anche l'odore non ti
preoccupare precari adesso tutto è
perdere come piacente devo per forza
berno dai simply che insieme allora ti
piace buonissimo mi sento un po strana
[Musica]
ma se questo vestito così fatto quel che
ha trasformato il violino del maestro
delle veramente lei ultimamente tutti
volete trasformarmi in qualcosa di
meraviglioso
mi dispiace dirti che io non sono alice
massa umanità arrivati
così vale sapevo che non dovevo bene
questo come faccio a tornare come prima
dovrai trovare i giudici di fare una
slide notizie c'è solo una piccola
regola che regola il tempo si rompe e
vedrò se tu riesci
non posso dire assolutamente no perché
non ho visto il tempo di volta in volta
con parlerò all'improvviso e di mesero
lazio nel tempo a dire ok ragazzi scuri
diamoci abbiamo poco tempo anche per sé
non so quanto tempo abbiamo proviamo a
salire al piano di ciao ciao
ok sbrighiamoci quali a volpiano di
sopra
speriamo che il tempo sia abbastanza
andiamo molto carino direi questo
vestito credit and me sta bene questo
vestito devo dire che il colore mi piace
un sacco anche se forse mi sta un po
largo per fortuna questa volta non ho
cambiato colore di capelli in crisi
berlino si è arrivati giusto in tempo
per aiutarmi a trovare
ok grazie villa berlino non mi dire che
ti sei alleato con il cappellaio matto
non capisco perché ma berlin ogni tanto
non mi aiuta e ogni tanto mi aiuta e
colombi liti a trovare gli ingredienti
che ne pensi
dove controlla
[Musica]
berlino la paletta in questo pupazzetto
sarà un amico del cappellaio grazie
berlino
non so se sia andato lì solo per
mangiarsi pikachu oppure perché mi
volevi indicare l'ingrediente comunque
abbiamo già una moretta siamo già in
vantaggio e merlino non è che mi
interessa è trovare anche gli altri sta
guardando fuori forse sappiamo uscire in
giardino
aiutami marino dove sono gli altri sopra
linea nocchiere di niente dovrò trovarli
da sola però almeno mi ha aiutato a
trovare la paletta
guardiamoci bene intorno vediamo se qua
c'è qualcosa io c'è qualcosa nascosto
qua penserò mimetizzata benissimo che
strano in genere la che cosa c'è top
il tempo sta passando quanto ti può
ancora ancora un po ma non troppo ok
l'arrivo già trovate due cose guarda ho
trovate la con sa bene ora vado a
cercarmi andiamo il piano si sta 8 mista
è la paletta ora mancano solamente la
soluzione progetti il bicarbonato e la
ciotola e se voi vedete qualcosa mi
raccomando scrivete malamente testa di
okaka maria improvviso non è che
potresti dirmi quanto tempo mi manca un
quarto minuto con si saluta che abbiamo
così sotto niente
aiutami parlerò ultimo tempo di aiutarmi
insomma qualcosa ci siamo quasi
siamo tempo fossero i suoi amici sanno
qualcosa
il topino
[Musica]
volevo farti del male che mi dimetto
perché importunando questa mattina c'è
qualcosa che 8 è il nostro non c'è
niente questo strano ma l'ho vista
[Applauso]
berlino aiutami timido verità volato
merlino ho bisogno dentro aiuto
altrimenti rimarrà dice per sempre la
potremo più file video assieme dovrà
rimanere in questo posto dov'è finito il
cappellaio matto è scomparso berlino
[Musica]
aveva nascosto quale basterebbe vediamo
sempre così spinosi non so dove sia
finito lui ma non si chiama simon così
forse tornano come prende coi ragazzi
abbiamo tutto tagliamo il tifoso che la
canon e inter ha una funzione magnifica
[Musica]
ok ragazzi il cappellaio è scomparso
nuovamente non so perché comunque
andiamo a mettere la colla bellissima e
celeste glitterata
ora abbiamo la fortuna per lenti e il
bicarbonato
c'è qualcosa che non va ragazze ho
iniziato a mescolarlo ma non si sta
creando lo slime forse il cappellaio
ammesso qualche ingrediente è strano qua
in mezzo pro ora non c'è come faccio a
chiederglielo signor cappellaio chakwal
quadra che non cosa signor cappellaio
signor cappellaio signor cappellano ma
la foto tutto il tempo ma solo m
c'è qualcosa che non va
tutto nello zaino ma non si addensa che
cosa devo fare
devi aggiungere troppo telescopi sono
l'ingrediente segreto con un giorno un
tempo
che cosa faccio ma se devo provare a
mettere qualcosa che c'è su quanto
tavolo sicuramente non queste ultime si
trasformerebbe lo slime in un alice nel
paese delle meraviglie accorse
se qua sopra il maledetto scusi signor
topino non volevo fargli del male
che cosa è questo
chester quale dovrò usare di questi tre
è sicuramente non questo per la
maledizione del morte il celeste
potrebbe essere in celeste perché tutto
celeste ma magari è una trappola oppure
potrebbe essere il nuovo al bar per
quale motivo potrebbe essere causati non
lo so quindi l'unico che mi viene il
celeste perché si abbina a tutto quello
che ho trovato io proverò con questo
formato sia succede succede quello ti
vagliate lo slavo non s tic toc toc
valore fondeva strada mentre qui che
giusto un pochino più muscolare forse
troppo forse scelto quello sbagliato si
sta sciogliendo tutto si ragazzi
istituzionale dello stato
signora mescolare superiore che musica
per tempo è riuscito vuoi sono stati
celeste un pò sigg.ri bellissimo quindi
mi dispiace per te signor cappellaio fa
ho vinto nel challenge non so neanche
quanto tempo mi restasse ma sono
riusciti a superare tutte le prove
ok hai vinto mesta charlie anche questa
volta ma se questo signore aggiunge
40.000 bicchiere beh allora ci sarà una
nuova chance mondo più pubblicata
toccata va bene vedremo se raggiungerà
perché mi piace bene allora che si è
imposta che si ritrasforma in anita
all'ingente meno prontissima 31 sono
tornate sono più alice però devo dire
che il tanto divertente questa challenge
con i miei amici andrà in un'altra casa
a festeggiare non complicate delle altre
persone perché no
a presto allora devo dire che questo
challenge stata super divertente ma ora
vi lasciamo fa 4 caselline se puoi
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate pure su quella che preferite e
moralizzare ciao
[Musica]